well hello there I'm Tom Scott as as
herb mentioned I'm for the University of
York although believe me today I am most
definitely not representing them in the
next eight minutes just like Hans
Rosling I have some graphs for you to
start off with this is Twitter this is
the times per day you post a Twitter
versus the amount I could give as you
can see as soon as you pass one tweet
today I couldn't give a rat's ass and
once you pass two a day I couldn't give
a monkey's are the pink line there the
little dotted pink line that's an
exception that's if I'm trying to get
into your pants this is the percentage
of people that understand the difference
between bar charts and line charts it's
kind of ironic because that should
really be a pie graph this is the number
of audiences I've shown this chart to if
that's the number of audiences who've
laughed at it that's close enough this
is a pantomime
this is the time I intend to go to bed
versus the time I actually go to bed the
blue line the blue line is normal the
red line is if I have an internet
connection this is how awesome hand
zimmer theme tunes are hand Zimmy is a
very very famous film composer he's been
composing for years and years
first of all Pirates of the Caribbean
now not only is that a fantastic bit of
music it's now become shorthand for
pirates you play that music and everyone
knows what you're talking about that's
quite awesome number two gladiator now
not only does that bring a tear to the
eye of grown men at the end of the movie
it the whole score that whole score
redefined film music ever since that
came out that's even more awesome the
last hand Zimmer theme tune and you
think I'm joking you think I just put
that in for a laugh but there it is
music by hand Zimmer believe it or not
can you imagine can you imagine what
would have happened if Han Zimmer had
been in a different mood when he'd
compose the theme music for going for
gold
the whole show takes on this epic battle
between nations and then suddenly Henry
Kelly walks our husband but that's not
quite as awesome as if handsome had been
a different mood
when he composed the theme music for
gladiator
[Music]
girl let's welcome your host Andrea kami
I think we can all agree that that's
significantly more awesome than either
of those this is how much the DJ talks
versus how much I want them to die the
red line is me the blue line is
Morrissey two drums the cymbal fall off
a cliff
yes the dunk exactly right you see you'd
think that but then we actually went and
tested it Matt a friend of mine yes
this is how I spend on an idea versus
the chance of it succeeding not that I'm
bitter I spent I spent hours now is
putting together a really complicated
video about Apple inventing a heads-up
display nothing I'll spend 1-2 hours
putting together a website that recovers
deleted Twitter messages from anyone's
account goes everywhere fantastic
Gapminder Gapminder hasn't hands Rossi's
Gapminder is an amazing thing is you can
chart so many things like what I've done
here as you all know what's happening
tomorrow this is the Eurovision Song
Contest as you can see what we have here
is 1957 the dates at the bottom left
those red countries they're the Western
countries there the traditional
Eurovision countries and as time goes on
that's on the x-axis we've got the
number of entries that got the the
y-axis there the y-axis is the 5 year
rolling average of their score took me
hours to put this together right 1994
look at that see all those on the left
of blue and the Greens there on the old
bulken state and the Soviet and the
Soviet states have all broken apart and
they've come in to Eurovision in 1994
but look on the right all the red
countries they're still all over the
places no and still no pattern there of
them they've been there longer but watch
the late 90s to the early 2000s tele
voting appears tele voting appears in
the Eurovision Song Contest and watch
those red dots on the right down they go
down they go not only not only do we
have block voting there's the United
Kingdom 2007 look back here if I can
grab that little thing there look at
this in 1980 in the 1980s we have right
at the top that's Katrina and the waves
happening there the only the only one
higher than us the only one higher than
us is Ireland just about here there they
are at that point the Irish broadcast
was pretty much bang but watch this how
do we go down we go televoting came in
and I can't think of anything we could
have done around 2002 it could have
affected our standing on the world stage
as much as that you know what else could
possibly have that effect
misses people who are red-green color
blind
as we can see from this graph everyone
who is red-green color blind is a normal
productive member of society this is how
long I've got left in time unemployed
it's not a joke I just thought I'd
mention it this is Carly's law
Carly's law as time goes on if you leave
a man in a room alone with a tea cosy
the probability that he will wear it on
his head approaches one I have some
evidence of this I have some evidence
this is Richard this is a friend of mine
I left him in a room with a tea cosy and
a hidden camera as you can see at one
minute he has noticed the tea cosy but
at five minutes he's still showing a
head he's not going for it then all of a
sudden seven minutes BAM
there it is there it is and by eight
minutes by eight minutes he is raising
the roof and performing papal blessings
it's amazing
this
this is the last one this is the final
one on the x-axis is the amount of
effort on the y-axis is the amount of
Awesome if it's in the red zone you do
it if it's in the blue zone you don't do
it that's not a joke it's just a way to
live your life thank you very much Ivan
Tom Scott goodnight
[Applause]